[Music]
this is Rick's thing you want a Golden
Globe for House of Lies and I understand
the next day you were very humble about
winning this award is that correct well
I think humility is something that you
need to have in this business so yeah
like really humbling okay I think we
have a picture this is a real picture of
you on the set of House of Lies to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
really happen there well I'm wearing it
yeah of course you have to wear it yes
if you win a Golden Globe mount it on
your car or wear it yeah that's yes to
it so I showed up for the table read and
as you can see they had some other props
for me to wear yeah and you look really
reluctant to wear those props you seem
well I thought the sceptre may have been
a little too far but yeah the goblet was
a nice touch it's a huge huge honor for
you were you surprised that you want I
was completely shocked I mean I really
was if you when you see my reaction
because um I really thought louis c.k
was gonna win yeah and he was about two
tables down and I had some bit I was
gonna trip him or like attack him or
punch him so I was completely unprepared
but they said my name and I was like oh
I got to get it together but I was so
sort of shell-shocked I forgot to thank
people then the whole thing's never what
happens I mean people always get up
there and say oh I had no idea I was
gonna win you really had no idea so
absolutely in that moment you forgot
important people yeah I didn't say the
name of this show creator the guy didn't
his show I didn't thank him that's kind
of important yeah well do you do you
want to thank anyone I mean you're on TV
now you want to thank anyone now that
you that you can I can get a second bite
of the Apple sure yeah that would be
great look why don't we can we do the
whole thing like it would really I mean
can I go get oh you want to go in the
crowd
[Applause]
we just sit here we'll show
[Applause]
okay the nominees are guy I hugged
earlier during the monologue and Don
Cheadle and the winner is rip rip rip
Don Cheadle
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man this is unexpected
Wow I would there's just so many people
that I have to thank obviously the cast
and crew who've been so important to the
House of Lies David Nevins and Matt
Blanca Showtime
Randhir uncle Gary Levine thank you guys
[Applause]
you
[Music]